how do you guys think that the finale
launches us into the next season I know
it's not we have you know talked about
what's going to happen in season with
six now but but there's definitely an
Avenue there yeah I believe the ending
uh of Cobra Kai definitely opens a lot
of new doors and opportunities and uh
possible outcomes of the show and pretty
much I think it shows that Cobra Kai
Never Dies what una says even though you
think that it might be done and you
think that the rain is over it's really
not
do you think we'll get Terry silver
coming back do you feel like there's any
way that a character like Terry silver
just goes down because he gets
handcuffed and put into them I think
there's no stop in tearing silver any
guy that evil with that much money he's
gonna find a way to get back get us but
we'll be ready I mean the crease
misdirect what was your impression of
that that was now that he's not dead
he's out and he's escaped from jail
please I'm begging you for what
Mercy that doesn't bode well for our
friends does it definitely not
especially after how Johnny and Daniel
left things with him in the prison so
we'll be training stopping us doing
anymore at first we always had the you
know nice assurance that they're not
going to do anything that illegal but
not anymore who knows yeah he's out for
blood now there's a lot of illegal stuff
happening
somebody should call the government
oh my gosh yeah I mean the end there we
we straight up we committed so many
felonies
yes yeah we've broken please beat
everyone up
Silver's dividing and conquering if this
continues all that we have fought for
will not even be Memory I need you to
see which of my students are ready to
take the next step
okay in your own words how would you
describe how intense the Rivalry is this
season between Cobra Kai and the
miyagudo eaglefang group we've been
talking about this all day is that like
the stakes are just like it went from
zero to 100 this season I mean it is by
the end we are all out it is intense you
know and I think the bigger and bigger
it gets the more everyone's drawn into
it so even characters like Anthony who
did not want to be part of this karate
world is now a part of it so I think
that you can just see by the sheer
amount of people that are involved that
this has gotten way out of hand the
fight scenes they've always been great
on the show but this season they feel
more brutal they feel like street fights
this season
oh yeah
adult classes are on Wednesday we're not
here to take a lesson we're here to
teach you one
what was it like shooting me I believe
shooting all these scenes were
incredible I mean it was just really fun
to learn the choreography and be able to
work with all these different characters
and some performers and having each
other was really important for us
because you know at times we did
struggle but we had each other to build
each other up and I think it was just
really cool to fight and have a great
time on set it's really showing on
camera what do you think when you're
watching these fights back you're like
oh my God this this is way more intense
than past Seasons yes yeah of course I
mean I I think all of it felt so in the
moment while we were filming it because
a lot of times they were adjusting moves
and um changing the fight choreography
or we're learning it in between takes
and so it all just felt so intense but
it seems like the story lines are really
focusing on the adults this season on
the the Rivalry between silver and
Johnny and Daniel and chosen as well and
the kids they're definitely involved but
it's like they've got a back burner
rivalries happening Dallas and I have
been able to play out this rivalry
between us really last two seasons and I
think luckily we still get to do stuff
with that but I think it's been really
fun to see the adult rivalry as well and
how really we're all connected and
obvious because it's like everybody
hates everybody at this point or love
them everybody's got an animated buddy I
think it's really interesting to see how
these all connect by the end of the
season do you do you guys feel like
Dallas your character went from being
bullied to being a bully does he see
Cobra Kai for what it is now I
personally believe that he sees Cobra
Kai for what it is I mean it shows it in
the evidence on camera you see pretty
much what happens in between the
interaction with Terry silver and Tori I
mean it's hurtful and it breaks your
heart but it's the truth so pretty much
I think he sees Cobra Kai for what it is
even though he doesn't want to believe
do you think he'll be able to patch
things up with Anthony and with Robbie I
think it's going to be easier to pack
things up with Robbie more than Anthony
yeah just because that whole battle
between Anthony and Kenny is so complex
and intricate even though the
relationship between Robbie and Kenny's
is complex as well well I just think
it's going to be tougher to you know
mend the relationship between you and
Anthony and I you know what about for
your character I mean she started any I
believe was Eagle Fang right and then
right went to COBRA Kai just because she
you know was committed what do you feel
like her head is at at the end of the
season she just wants to keep learning
and growing from her peers and just keep
getting better and I'm excited to see
where that leads are in the future
[Music]